aurélien voulait pas retrouvé non loin
de notre vie doit pas être venu de
l'assemblée allait bien écouté tout
d'abord bonne année on peut prendre
aussi quelques quelques instants pour se
souhaiter bonne année vous comme nous on
a des des métiers des activités où la
pression la réactivité la passion aussi
est bon font partie de notre quotidien
donc on peut aussi pour le temps de se
souhaiter bonne année parce qu'on a
toutes et tous des des familles et bon
vouloir des moments aussi on a besoin de
se retrouver et de partir du bon pied
donc c'est ce qu'on se souhaite à tous
et à toutes
alors pour ce qui concerne des
républicains mais tout d'abord vous dire
que nous sommes en ordre de bataille à
partir de cette semaine les forums
démarre vous avez déjà annoncé une
douzaine de forums qui était qui allait
être lancée sur différents sujets de
société qui préoccupe et qui intéresse
nos compatriotes dont c'est s'est engagé
avec à chaque fois l'organisation vis à
vis président mais au delà
un petit noyau de parlementaires souvent
trois parlementaires un député national
un député européen
un sénateur aurélien voilà nous rejoint
et puis systématiquement des élus locaux
élus territoriaux qui sont dans le dans
l'équipe
et puis une mobilisation importante
d'experts de représentants de la société
civile c'est plus de 80 experts qui nous
ont rejoints pour animer ces ces
différents groupes alors qu'ils viennent
de l'administration du monde de
l'entreprise du réseau associatif etc
ils sont nombreux et c'est essentiel
pour nous dans cet esprit qui avait été
le nôtre dès le départ de dire sur ces
forums
il y a les parlementaires quand l'étions
leur leur expertise souvent une
expertise nationale mais on veut avoir
des élus territoriaux qui sont
confrontés à la réalité des territoires
et les représentants de la société
civile ensuite sur les six mois qui
viennent
au delà des réunions régulières à peu
près au rythme d'une fois par mois sur
chacun de nous de nos forums
3-3 convention nous allons à tenir ici
sur trois trois volets assure le la
première sera sur le volet social et
portera sur le handicap c'est c'est
aurélien qui l'animera elle se tiendra
le 4 mars est la date est déjà déjà calé
on en aura une deuxième sur le volet
régalien autorités de l'état c'est
frédéric péchenard fred sais pas si nous
rejoindre non
ensuite la troisième se tiendra au mois
de juin sur le volet économique donc là
ce sera pouvoir pouvoir d'achat c'est
guillaume qui l'animera et tout cela va
nous va nous conduire au congrès des
idées le 4 le 4 juillet donc confirmera
le lieu ce sera ce sera paris mais on en
train de boucler le lieu d'ici là on va
avoir le grand rendez vous des élections
municipales c'est un enjeu important
pour nous de de conforter notre notre
base territoriale et dans la foulée de
ces municipales on aura un conseil
national qui nous permettra à la fois
d'analyser les résultats de nos
municipal et puis de lancer notre
congrès des idées ce sera un moment d'un
rendez vous important avec l'ensemble dé
l'ensemble des cadres de notre famille
politique les forums sont déjà engagés
certaines conventions ora auront eu lieu
et on sera là mi-temps entre le début
d'année et le congrès des idées du mois
de du mois de juillet ensuite fin août
28 et 29 août à nîmes nous aurons notre
rentrée notre rentrée politique il y
aura une seule rentrée politique vous
savez que l'on a vu le débat sur
différentes universités les années
précédentes bon tout ça a été
complètement clarifier et ce sera un
grand rendez vous de la jeunesse pour
cette rentrée politique c'est bon pierre
henri dumont qui est en train de
préparer préparer tout cela c'est
essentiel pour nous pour nous aussi
d'avoir ce grand rassemblement de jeunes
et cette rentrée politique dernier
week-end d'août qui se déclinera sans
doute avec des rentrées régionales donc
il n'y aura pas cette année il y aura
pas d université du touquet comme les
années précédentes la baule ce sera
centré sur dans un cadre régional et ce
sera après
le rendez vous de la jeunesse de nîmes
donc de façon pour bien marquer à la
fois notre entrée mais aussi de le faire
avec
avec la jeunesse c'était un point
essentiel pour nous ensuite l'année
continuera avec la préparation d'un 2e
congrès des idées qui se tiendra
vraisemblablement en décembre ou janvier
21 mais plutôt plus tôt en décembre
on n'a pas encore arrêté les thèmes des
conventions qu'ils prépareront mais bon
je pense qu'on sera plutôt sur les
sujets énergie climat fracture
territoriale et puis aussi la jeunesse
parce qu'on aura les enseignements à
tirer de ce grand rendez vous avec les
jeunes donc on verra à ce moment là mais
au moins les deux thèmes et énergie
climat fracture territoriale sont des
points des points importants parce que
là aussi fracture territoriale en tirera
les enseignements des municipales sur
l'actualité de delà de la rentrée au
moins deux vont en avoir plusieurs mais
2,2 sujet le sujet vous avez déjà évoqué
celui de la circulaire castaner c'est un
point important pour pour nous on est
face à une manipulation je pense comme
on l'a rarement été de la part du
ministre de l'intérieur donc cette
circulaire nous la contestons elle est
contestée d'ailleurs dans l'est dans les
territoires nous allons nous avons
déposé un recours sur trois trois angles
home ou moins celui de l'incompétence
juridique d'abord parce qu'une
circulaire ne peut pas modifier un
décret c'est une règle de base
ensuite sur ce seuil des 9000 qui un
seuil totalement arbitraire qui n'existe
nulle part ailleurs qu' il n'a qu'un
intérêt politiciens pour la le parti au
pouvoir pour le parti remplace mais
autrement on ne voit pas d'où sort ce
seuil
et puis le détournement de pouvoirs au
sens juridique du terme c'est à dire que
cette circulaire ne répond à aucun en
aucun cas à l'intérêt général
elle ne répond qu'un intérêt partisan du
parti politique au pouvoir
mais au-delà de ça il n'y a aucun
intérêt à 7 à cette circulaire on a à la
fois le sujet du seuil
est ce le sujet de ce classement en
divers centres qui serait l'apanage de
la république en marche si vous voulez
prendre un cas d'école
vous auriez dans une dans une ville au
deuxième tour deux listes qui
s'affronteraient une du parti communiste
et du front du front national si la
république en marche apporté son soutien
au parti communiste
il serait inédit que le parti communiste
gaye il serait immédiatement classé
divers centres c'est ça la circulaire
c'est une aberration et avec un intérêt
qui est purement politicien on est
vraiment dans la manoeuvre dans la
combine
et je pense qu'il ya tout de même point
de vue toutes les raisons que cette
circulaire puisse être revu à la fois
sur le seuil
mais aussi sur le système de classement
les deux sujets sont posées et puis
dernier
dernier point je voulais évoquer
rapidement avec vous c'est sur les
chiffres de la délinquance
ils viennent d'être rendues publiques
bon vous avez là aussi entendu les
commentaires font ça c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est alain bauer qui le kill qui
le dit ce sont les chiffres les pires
depuis 40 ans je le
je le cite quand on regarde un peu dans
le détail les coups et blessures
volontaires c'est plus lui pour cent
cette année
c'est à dire que depuis l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macron c + 21 % les violences
sexuelles c'est 12% d'augmentation cette
année après 19
l'année dernière les homicides ses huit
ennemis
brice oui oui jo je vois je vois il ya
un enseignement à tirer c'est que ce
sujet de la sécurité n'a pas été pris au
sérieux par ce gouvernement et notamment
par le le ministre de l'intérieur les
chiffres qui sont là sont
catastrophiques nous dit quand bauer dit
que ce sont les pires depuis depuis 40
ans d'abord ça nous permet d'accord avec
lui sur l'analyse mais mais au-delà de
cela c'est assez grave d'avoir ce
ministre de l'intérieur on pourrait
d'ailleurs ajouté un autre point sur la
baisse du budget sur l'équipement ddd
policiers on doit être 6 ou 7% j'ai pu
les chiffres exacts en tête de baisse de
leur budget d'équipement
donc il ya vraiment une non prise en
compte de cette réalité qui est celle
que nos compatriotes connaissent face à
la délinquance
voilà moi les quelques points je voulais
évoquer avec vous en ce jour de rentrée
et puis
bon après je vous propose qu'on ait un
échange ne peut-être guillaume anies
aurélien je voulais ajouter un mot à
chacun d'entre vous nous sommes
totalement en phase avec très bonne
année à chacun d'entre vous nous sommes
totalement en phase les uns les autres
avec ce que vient d'exprimer christian
et puisque ce début d'année semble être
placé sous le signe de la concorde dit
on vous rappeler que ici dans cette
équipe
autour de christian jacob avec les uns
les autres nous travaillons dans cet
esprit d'unité d'apaisement et de
concorde qui était le premier engagement
qui avait porté christian jacob
lorsqu'il a été élu et puis la deuxième
étape qui est la nôtre de manière
collective c'est d'essayer de façonner à
nouveau une ligne politique un projet
politique
les républicains c'est le parti du
travail c'est le parti de l'ordre c'est
le parti aurélien le démontrera au moins
de mars aussi des solidarité de la
fraternité et celles que nous entendons
démontrer les uns et les autres dans cet
esprit tout au long de l'année 2020 bien
le président a tracé la feuille de route
le calendrier de l'année à venir je
voulais vous dire que vraiment notre
notre mouvement est au travail il est
plein d'enthousiasmé plein d'espoir
aussi notamment pour ces élections
municipales qui approche et comme cela a
été dit nous ne nous laisserons pas
dérobé le résultat de ce scrutin
donc on entend bien faire échec à la
manoeuvre politicienne du gouvernement
qui veut effacer le résultat la réalité
du résultat des municipales vous dire
aussi en qualité de président du conseil
national que notre premier conseil
national a été un succès de
fréquentation d'abord et puis aussi dans
l'expression je crois que ça a fait du
bien ou conseillers nationaux d'exprimer
ce qu'ils avaient sur le coeur et le
retour que nous en avons c'est qu'ils
ont le sentiment que voilà une nouvelle
étape s'est engagée et que la dynamique
et là et nous aurons donc un second
conseil national après les municipales
c'est l'expression des territoires dans
notre mouvement c'est très important
vous avez que les républicains sont et
entendent être le parti de l'expression
du territoire c'est pour ça que nous
sommes pleins d'espoir par rapport aux
municipales mais ce conseiller national
c'est vraiment l'expression du parti
dans nos territoires et je crois que ils
ont montré qu'ils étaient au rendez-vous
de de cette étape importante de la
reconstruction de notre mouvement
bonne année à vous tous et puis un petit
message personnel n'oubliez pas qu'il ya
des femmes dans l'équipe dirigeante des
républicains
donc je parle avec ma collègue virginie
duby muller donc il y à des experts
parmi nous il ay ay ay compris dans le
domaine politique donc voilà un message
à vous tous chers amis merci je vais
très original en souhaitant une
excellente année à chacune et chacun
d'entre vous ce simplement vous dire que
2009 a été une année pour nous de
travail
c'est pas un mot galvaudé que de le dire
notre mouvement est véritablement au
travail nous avions d'ailleurs pris des
rendez vous devant vous que nous avons
tous tenus sur un ensemble de
thématiques les engagements qui avaient
été pris sur la mise en place des forums
peut être avez vous perçu au départ
qu'il s'agissait juste d'animer notre
mouvement pas du tout c'est une
véritable stratégie qui a été porté par
christian jacob et que nous développons
progressivement c'est la stratégie des
idées avant de traiter d'autres
questions plus plus individuelle et
personnelle et vous observerez sûrement
assez objectivement que en 2019 à chaque
fois que nous vous avons dit que nous
allions investir un sujet et le faire
sur le fond nous l'avons fait tous les
rendez-vous qui ont été pris ont été
tenus en 2020 ils seront encore plus
nombreux à l'être la feuille de route
est extrêmement précises extrêmement
claire premier de thèmes qui va nous
occuper parce que nous croyons en la
politique qui cherchent des solutions
quotidien ce premier thème sera celui du
handicap
nous allons y travailler dès la semaine
prochaine pour nous amener au premier la
première convention nationale sur cette
grande cause qui sera celle du handicap
et qui pendant plusieurs semaines va
nous permettre
d'investir ou plutôt de réinvestir un
sujet sur lequel la droite républicaine
a beaucoup à dire a beaucoup fait
historiquement depuis de nombreuses
années on voit qu'à chaque fois sur ces
thèmes là on ne s'égare pas on se
retrouve on revient au fil conducteur
qui nous ont toujours guidé et on tâche
de faire en sorte que notre famille
politique qui est une véritable chers
politiques et sûrement est ce quelque
chose de nécessaire pour la droite mais
aussi est-ce quelque chose de nécessaire
pour la vie de notre démocratie et pour
la vie politique en général qui à notre
sens ment beaucoup de chair depuis de
nombreux mois et quelques années et donc
en 2020 nous serons au travail chacun à
notre place avec nos différences de
personnalité mais avec une volonté
commune qui est de faire avancer la
droite républicaine et de pouvoir nous
adresser à nouveau aux françaises et aux
français
bonne année à toutes et à tous et
souhaitons qu'en 2020 nous soyons pour
les républicains aussi épuisé à la tâche
que nous avons pu l'être en 2019
il ya ce que je propose c'est parce
qu'il ya quelques questions on les prend
là puis après toute façon on va avoir
l'occasion autour d'un verre je crois
même un peu plus de continuer attendez
où il prenait le micro est sur un cycle
à castanet rhin mer et l'air soutenu et
avec des héroïnes sur sa liste comment
se terrer vous qu'elle soigne aussi par
les intérieurs
le classement est celui du maire est ce
que le maire ait l air ou pas à partir
du moment
enfin ce serait un comble on n'a jamais
vu ça auparavant tous les laits maire
rpr je l'étais ump je l'étais aussi et
l'air aussi fort des listes de
rassemblement
on a toujours fait ça dans les
municipales mais je n'ai jamais imaginé
quand j'étais rpr qu'on me claes udf
ou oui à l'époque c'était et l udf ou
autre ça n'a pas de sens le classement
est celui qui conduit la liste celui du
maire ça me semble une évidence comment
n'ont cessé que non non non si si c'est
comme ça que c'est peu puisque quand
vous êtes le préfet vous interroge le
maire déclare sans appartenance
politique
voilà mes mais déclare son appartenance
politique non il ya deux choses
il ya à la fois et c'est pour ça qu'il
ya une double inquiétude pour nous le la
taille de population des villes parce
que ça ça veut dire aussi mais c'est
giresse et malheureusement conforme à ce
que les français ressentent depuis
l'arrivée de cette nouvelle équipe
gouvernementale c'est un certain mépris
pour les territoires ruraux et à partir
du moment où vous n'êtes pas dans une
commune de plus de 9000 habitants
vous êtes considéré qu'une certaine
forme de mépris qu'on vous prend pas en
compte sauf si vous êtes chef-lieu
d'arrondissement quelle est la
différence entre une ville de 7000
habitants chef lieu d'arrondissement et
une qui ne l'est pas donc nous on est à
la fois là dessus et sur ce classement
se nuance âge qui a toujours été celui
de l'éthique est d'humeur en tout cas on
y attacher pardon monsieur jacob
benjamin biolay pour bfm tv hier soir au
vieux métiers nicolas sarkozy s'est
inquiété de scènes de violence qui
traverse la france depuis plusieurs mois
est ce que vous interprétez sa commun
comme une comédie comme une leçon faite
au président actuel comme une commune a
l'air tout simplement comme une parole
d'un ancien chef de l'état comment
est-ce que vous interprétez ses propos
le meilleur pour interpréter les propos
nicolas sarkozy c'est nicolas sarkozy
vous conseille de le poser la question à
lui ce que je veux dire au delà de cela
ces scènes de ya une tension comme
jamais on ne l'a on l'a connu moi on
touche là on fait nos cérémonies de
voeux dans nos communes de différentes
tailles
c'est toujours l'occasion de rencontrer
énormément de monde on sent une tension
très forte partout et ses scènes de
violence sont sont ceux sont
inquiétantes et sont révélatrices heures
ya à la fois la nécessité de l'autorité
et de la fermeté et l'ambiguïté qui a
été la marque de fabrique au départ
c'est à dire quant au moment de notre
dame des landes
on sait tous aux casseurs et aux voyous
a donné un signe certain moment où
certains se sont dit mais finalement
est-ce qu'il ne faut pas casser pour
être entendu quand on ajoute à cela le
mépris des élus avec les opérations
balances ton mer et autres le mépris des
corps des corps intermédiaires fait
qu'effectivement des gens se disent mais
est ce qu'ils font pas de violents pour
pour arriver à se faire entendre et
sacré d un climat de tension qui est
extrêmement grave donc à la fois l'état
doit faire preuve d'autorité dire
respect au droit des biens et des
personnes sans sans ambiguïté mais par
ailleurs qu il y aussi des signes de
dialogue et d'écouté
ce qui est ressenti comme une forme de
mépris de condescendance et de
suffisance dans l'expression de nombreux
membres du gouvernement et parfois même
du président de la république lui-même
créé contribuer à créer ce climat de
forte tension
concernant justement prolongement des
réflexions sur les tensions est ce que
vous pensez également qu'il ya un
problème de doctrine delà de la police
et une forme d' escalade de doctrine de
l' escalade qui ne se perçoit plus dans
les autres pays européens doctrine de
l'escale doctrine de l' escalade c'est
ce qu'on appelle devant cette violence
qui répond à la violence qui répond à
une violence encore plus grande
alors que certains pays européens ont
mis en place chez par forces de l'ordre
une doctrine de la désescalade pour
justement éviter cette épidémie de
violence manière générale en matière de
maintien de l'ordre la france est
souvent été considéré comme une
référence avec à avec des des forces de
police et des forces de maintien de
l'ordre qui sont de très grands
professionnels
il ya une pression aussi énorme qu'amis
et à la manière dont ils sont sollicités
regardez depuis depuis deux ans la
mobilisation qui a été qui était la leur
après moi je suis pas un expert dans le
domaine mais ce que je ce que je
considère c'est que aujourd'hui
l'autorité elle doit être incarnée avec
calme avec sérénité mais sans ambiguïté
et ayez quelques signes au début du
quinquennat qui ont été mal compris et
mal les mal ressenti ensuite quand il y
à des excès individuels ou des
débordements bien entendu ils sont
inadmissibles et condamnable ça ne fait
pas l'ombre d'une discussion
c'est bon ouais que pensez-vous de la
grève des avocats sur le haut au delà
des les avocats mais aussi l'ensemble
des caisses des caisses autonomes dans
le cadre de la ca permet de re dire un
mot sur la réforme des retraites
nous nous avons depuis le début une
ligne qui éclaire sans ambiguïté est
tenu par tous et un de dire qu'il ya la
nécessité d'avoir une réforme des
retraites et que l' équilibre budgétaire
de la réforme des retraites ne doit pas
passer par une augmentation de
cotisations ou de fiscalité ni par la
baisse des pensions
elle doit passer par une mesure d'âge
c'est à dire qu'il faut repousser l'âge
de départ légal à la retraite
ensuite le deuxième élément c'est la
sortie des régimes spéciaux et donc on a
proposé une douzaine douzaine d'années
pour s'aligner sur le système le système
général troisième élément la
reconnaissance de la pénibilité il y à
des métiers qui sont plus pénibles que
d'autres en france et qui doivent être
reconnus et qui doivent bénéficier d'une
possibilité de départ plus tôt à la
retraite
ça n'est pas lié à un statut ce n'est
pas lié à une condition c'est lié à
l'exercice d'un métier qui peut être
difficile et qui doit être reconnu en
tant que tel
donc pour cela on a pris comme base
qu'on appelle le cinquième qui existe
chez les ch et les militaires c'est à
dire que tous les saints après avoir
exercé pendant cinq ans un métier
pénible on gagne une année de bonus qui
permet limité à quatre ans permet de
pouvoir partir plus tôt à la retraite
ensuite 4e quatrième élément celui de la
politique familiale nous y sommes très
attachés et on voit bien que d'avoir
sabordé la politique familiale comme l'a
fait le gouvernement de françois
hollande comme continue allait faire le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron on voit
les courbes de la natalité qui sont en
train de bouger tout simplement ce qu'on
a abandonné la politique familiale
donc nous sommes pour la préservation
des droits familiaux et enfin au delà de
cela les caisses autonomes
reconnaissons et fichons la paix aux
caisses autonomes ces caisses autonomes
quel c est son pourquoi ils sont
excédentaires d'abord parce qu'elles
sont bien gérées ensuite parce que ils
ont prévu une pyramide démographique qui
risque de s'inverser c'est à dire qu'ils
sont souvent dans des situations où il
ya plus de cotisants que de pensionnés
c'est pour ça qu'elles sont
excédentaires mais aussi parce qu'ils
ont souvent des cotisations plus élevées
donc ils ont généré des excédents pour
pouvoir répondre à cette attente donc on
va pas les faire main basse sur leurs
financements pour le mettre dans un
système général qui est moins bien gérés
reconnaissons l'autonomie de ces de ces
caisses qui ne demandent rien à personne
donc ça va au delà des avocats mais ça
permettait de faire un petit rappel sur
les retraites et sur toutes les caisses
autonomes pas uniquement celle des
avocats
parce que d'autres professions sont
concernées de la même façon on m'a dit
vous en preniez la tête
ah ben c'est ce qui se dit partout bon
moi je vous laisse en parler avec lui
c'est un enjeu important je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure nous sommes ancrés sur le
territoire a ni le rappelait je pense
que nous sommes la famille politique qui
incarne le mieux les territoires et donc
c'est pour ça que cette élection
municipale
elle est importante pour nous on a
encaissé trois échecs successifs les
présidentielles les législatives les
européennes
donc on a effectivement comme toute
famille politique besoin de poser le
pied sur la terre ferme et la terre
ferme pour nous c'est celle des
municipales c'est celle des terroirs de
des terroirs et des territoires de
france c'est pour ça que c'est c'est un
enjeu important que nous sommes obligés
dessus ça y contribuera largement après
ça n'est pas de la victoire des
municipales qu'on fait une victoire aux
présidentielles et aux législatives
mais c'est un passage important pour
nous de stopper les après trois échecs
successifs et bien de retrouver les
capacités de rebond mais ce qui nous met
en situation de pouvoir demain aspirer à
nouveau à gouverner a dirigé la france
c'est ce travail sur le fond d'être
porteurs d'idées
c'est pour ça que après ce que disait
guillaume pelletier tout à l'heure après
avoir créé des conditions d'apaisement
dans notre famille politique c'est de se
remettre au travail
vous savez la ligne politique et ne se
décrète pas par le discours de tel ou
tel
et ce travail commun dans le collectif
est ce que nous faisons sur trois angles
à chaque fois vous voyez dans toutes nos
conventions on est on à 3-3 accroche qui
est n'accroche sociale elle été évoqué
tout à l'heure par par aurélien on a une
accroche sur l'autorité le régalien
c'est essentiel pour nous et l'eau
régalien c'est plus que l'autorité parce
que c'est l'enseignement c'est beaucoup
d'autres sujets dernière star et puis la
croche économique qui est importante et
la croche économique elle se fait en
prenant en compte le développement
durable la prise en compte du respect de
l'environnement
vous m'avez déjà entendu le décliner sur
le plan économique
moi sur ma conception de l'entreprise je
pense qu'une entreprise doit reposer sur
un trépied d'abord une rentabilité
économique il n'y a pas d'entreprise qui
tiennent sur la durée si elle n'est pas
rentable
ensuite elle doit être facteur de
progrès social
ceux qui travaillent doit bénéficier des
des résultats de l'entreprise c'est à
dire que les salariés doivent être les
premiers bénéficiaires aussi du résultat
de l'entreprise et troisième élément
préserver l'environnement
si on ne préserve pas l'environnement on
n'est pas dans la durabilité
donc on a tout ce travail de fond à
faire les élections son rendez vous
essentiel mais elles ne sont pas
suffisantes il faut avoir ce travail de
fond et c'est pour ça que nous sommes
engagés sur ces congrès des sur ces
congrès des idées donc 1 en juillet de
cette année un deuxième décembre ou
janvier prochain et un troisième en
juillet 21 l'enjeu ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas monsieur bouchons ce n'est pas le
15e en tant que tel c'est de faire en
sorte que sur dans tout paris tous les
électeurs qui se retrouvent dans la
candidature
heller incarné par rachida dati puisse
le faire puissent voter pour elle est
aujourd'hui la position qui est tenu par
par philippe goujon aujourd'hui ne
permet pas cela parce que philippe dit
écoutez moi d'abord vous m'élisez et
puis ensuite je verrai si j'apporte mes
voix à monsieur griveaux à monsieur
villani ou à madame dati
nous nous avons besoin sur l'ensemble
des arrondissements de paris que tous
les électeurs parisiens puissent voter
pour pour rachida dati de l'enjeu on le
sait bien sûr les municipales l'enjeu
c'est la mairie de paris
aujourd'hui la dynamique elle est dans
notre camp et quand vous regardez les
résultats qui sont qui sont ceux de
madame et de madame hidalgo aujourd'hui
pour un maire sortant bon je l'étais on
a un certain nombre ici l avoir été être
24 à 24 % quand on est maire sortant
croyez moi c'est inquiétant
et donc on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une vraie aspiration à l'alternance à
paris et celle qui est aujourd'hui créer
une dynamique c'est rachida dati elle
était au mois deux mois de septembre
dernier elle était à 14 points dans les
sondages au mois de décembre il était à
17 aujourd'hui elle est à 19 tout
simplement parce que c'est lié à sa
personnalité à son tempérament que les
uns et les autres connaissent bien et
les parisiens connaissent bien mais pas
que c'est lié à son projet elle est la
seule à incarner un vrai projet
d'alternance sur sur paris sur les
sujets de sécurité sur les sujets de
propreté sur le logement sur la mobilité
est là un vrai programme un vrai projet
et qui répond à une attente et à une
aspiration des parisiens et donc moi ce
que je veux c'est que dans l'es17
arrondissement de paris les parisiens
qui souhaitent voter et se retrouver
dans la liste de rachida dati et des
républicains puissent le faire c'est bon
eh bien merci
salut bon ben je démarre avec les bonnes
nouvelles mais déjà je trouvais 2 à
terme jour c'est la première fois qu'on
a vraiment quelqu'un d'honnête
le président wade républicain ça faisait
longtemps parce que